were you ever tempted to join the life
or no
i never got that close to join the life
no i i can't even say that did you get
an invitation was it kind of like hey
chaz you know you'd be great in the life
no no it was never that i know it was
more like you you get involved in a
small way you start doing the car they
were chopping up cars
you want to go there then you get these
chop up cars then you meet somebody else
and you meet a bigger boss and that's
how it happens i never i just never went
there i just didn't want to do it
if your father had different values to
teach you could that have happened
oh yeah so so let me ask you this
question because for me i'm always
trying to find a motive and what caused
somebody to go into that life when you
hear the story about some of these guys
with their fathers
it's like automatic okay this makes
sense this person is going to be it so
how much of it you think is the
individual that wants to be part of the
life how much you think it's the
influence of the parents oh the parents
oh you put it on the parents i'm saying
the parents definitely just you got it
because when you're young what is a
parent a parent is a mirror
kids watch the way you treat your wife
they watch what you do they watch you
get up in the morning and go to work
yeah if they see that they go oh that's
how she's supposed to be they grow up
and they mirror you you know if you
treat your wife bad they'll grow up
they'll treat their wife bad it's very
simple
so you really have to as a father you
got to watch them you got to you got to
my father led by example my mother led
by example and they loved me so much i
love my sisters i didn't want to hurt
them
my father said don't ever let me have to
come to jail to bail you out please
don't ever do that to me that would kill
me and i said i'll die don't worry about
it i wouldn't do that you know and i
didn't
you know sometimes when your parents are
do not set a good example if you have
the a good moral compass you might say
i'm never gonna be like my father i'm
never gonna do that i'm gonna do the
exact opposite i've seen
billy's father and that's the man that i
want to emulate and some people go down
a different route that's hard show me
show me people who could do that that
was me yeah i did not have a good
relationship with my father he was doing
some things i didn't agree with i said
i'm never going to be like you some
people can do also that yeah it's harder
it's harder it's harder but it is
impossible it is possible just because
you know but it shows it shows the it
shows the value of
uh but but there is a part that affected
you though i mean if you think about it
there's certain things in life that
probably how hard is it for you to find
somebody right now that you want to make
your wife how hard is it for you because
it's you're you're overthinking it like
what if it doesn't work what if it's
this what if it's that because there's a
part of that fear like i don't want to
ever get married to me it's like i'm
never going to get married because [ __ ]
i saw my parents get two divorces in 20
years i don't even want to deal with
this marriage stuff but i really wanted
to have kids and i wanted to have a
family i wanted to have that legacy type
of thing right so
it just tells you the power of parenting
man it tells you the power of parenting
had a friend of mine his dad would
always slap him in the face in front of
us and the kids would kick and this was
a grown kid that would slap him in the
face man i would walk away i'm like dude
i can't be in your house man i can't
come to your house so i can't watch you
that slap your face it makes me feel
uncomfortable i'm not cool with that
it's very very awkward to see that take
place and what happened with that guy
he's no longer with us man i just no
literally he's no longer with us so i
think the value of parenting man that's
the part where yes
you hear kids being raised without a
father or without a a mom and dad in a
picture it's got a big it's got a big
influence on that look look at crime
most of these kids in jail
they're 80 of them have no father that's
right
where are the fathers you know when you
get these kids eight nine ten years old
it's too late
you got to get them at that you got to
get them early
i i go to prisons i go to juvenile
prisons and i talked to some of the kids
okay
these kids are 14 years old they're like
men
they're like men yeah
they're talking about whacking people
double murders
come on where where were the parents
where were the parents where his mother
was a junkie his father was a
in the in the can yeah i mean what shot
does he have yeah what shot does this
kid have no shot nothing
it's the p you must get these kids early
purpose and accountability what are you
doing to father what do we do because
look we we're a nation of choices right
freedom of choice you get to choose to
use a condom or not nobody can force you
to say wait wait wait wait put it on
like we're not there to be able to catch
a situation right right so there's a lot
of
temptation when you're having sex you
know you're not thinking about it you
get pregnant baby comes father bales
dude i don't want to be a father i just
wanted to have some good sex i'm not i'm
not here to help you i don't even have
any money i can't do anything i can't be
in the picture what do you do in those
cases where the father's not there how
does the community how does the
state how does the country address that
i don't know yeah so that's a you know
it's funny i i was um many years ago i
was at spielberg's house and i was
talking to him about a project i never
forgot that
and
a little boy came out a little boy came
out
uh black he was black
very
beautiful
haircut and he had he was only about 10
years old maybe i think at the time he
had this like ralph lauren shirt pants i
mean really
stylish
and he said
and and he said chance this is my son
spielberg's son yes and i said oh he has
another son max that he has once
and again i'm not talking about i don't
i don't know stephen but i'm just
telling you the story
and he said this is my son and i went oh
very nice to meet you it was very hello
really you know
and then i i said wow and and i found
out that he
adopted him
that his parents i don't know
maybe they i i don't know if they
something somebody said they were crack
addicts i don't remember exactly but now
here's this young boy think of this
that if stephen doesn't adopt him
where is he
and now he went from there
to being one of the most influential
richest people in the world right what
how's his career going to be it's
you know stephen's introducing him to
life and
it's it's the parents mean everything in
a young child's life everything
people don't get it
but you got to get them early you got to
get them early so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you